welcome to this video play Oh balls
apply was that love keep forgetting with
this is this is mark to trail from
Belgium okay yeah I was remembering this
somehow but not one hundred percent sure
ok we have a gem modern defensive check
in a form that i J like for white here
King e8 really hmm I mostly play 97 okay
and put them put the King to c7 later
yeah in this sir particular position
it's important that why does some not
playing you for a weakening here's some
his big square on default White's plenty
is connected with g 4 i'm going to do
this right away g4 and later 94 bishop
see 39 ft 2 f for this is the way that
why it is normally proceeding here we
check me I guess reform
okay so he's just content with her with
blocking this not very attractive for
black but it's not like his own he's
falling apart quickly here night h6 is
this is idea maybe ticking but I can go
to age to win i won with the night at
first let's take this good spot here
maybe night c5 can also be an idea okay
Bishop to see three now or yeah I guess
I want tonight f.2d to being being
possible okay it's just taking on d7
this an idea when I guess not I guess
not I want I want to try to use the week
at five square later then I'm preparing
that night g3 and then maybe Knight to
f5 later it's f five squares week at
this is my one of my trump cards and he
cannot castle this is very important
night to d6 yeahh shall I just take this
and then 94 again check horribly pawn
takes 94 looks very awkward
okay now see going with night c5 maybe
maybe I can also think about rook h1 and
I think I should do that okay this is
just a fence hmm can I somehow get the
light squared Bishop sixth not that easy
night C fiber sir is helping him quite
quite a bit here
yeah that's it's all very very little
that I have here surprising not really
am not really any advantage hmm yeah
this I was thinking about this if this
is maybe an option for blackberry
thought I by capturing the h-bond would
be more of a weakness than a strengths
maybe I'm misjudging this okay let's do
it how do i how do I make any headway
here Brooke age three first blocking
this and five is not possible then F for
maybe f4 be should be one and it's
probably probably still equal ish I'm I
burned up lots of time for not very much
putting it mildly
high five it's a very very Bishop e3 you
such as nonsense he's coming with a five
now check I thought that five was more
dangerous time morning yeah yeah I don't
think I'm I'm in any any trouble check
king of force even a check made
Bishop g5 I Bishop g5 might give him my
turn give him some progress gap still
fairly so that he cannot cannot easily
easily push the ice cut the edge porn
but it still should be okay for me
30 seconds remove the main problem check
my king is also quite shattered check
check yeah getting his rook as well and
now my king is more active little bit
way to play the Zen game I'm just
winning now check check check mate
Charlie I should never win this of
course but every don't think he's got
much yet i'm still so pretty solid I
mean you should probably try to prevent
therefore somehow but not not quite not
quite sure how I cannot do much rook g7
I guess maybe rook g7 done
and c5 and b5 I mean black is better hmm
but how bad is it during the game me
being a natural up to mr. thought it's
nothing terrible but i think it is it is
really bad yeah i have a hard time here
because i cannot really move the
rockaway h3 is getting getting very very
very dangerous mm-hmm and then he gets
in b5 yeah this is very good for black
yeah somehow I mean I must have
misplayed it this this should be a
slight advantage for wide because of
their five square but maybe there is a
way to really explain it it's possible
what I would love to do is get the light
squared Bishop is exchange then I would
get the Knight to f5 but it's not easy
to accomplish ah therefore therefore is
innocent interesting the idea is that
here we look at this I have a good very
good position here Zack interesting and
one point is if he does not exchange if
he does something like that check there
is this move available which lets me the
exchange this isn't entirely clear
though look at this black black has good
minor pieces and he's got good bones
that's not a clear position computer
thinks why this better 0.7 but it's not
entirely clear here here there's simply
nothing and there must be a bit cautious
with Brooke age for coming yeah I
shouldn't take I shouldn't take relief
maybe this was was a
one of the one of the problems and this
is definitely wrong but sugar 3 I
thought he could have here I thought you
should have played f5 check not this and
so I really don't don't mind these
trades I thought instead you should do
f5 and I thought this would be quite
good for black [ __ ] maybe it's not that
bad but like it's certainly better i am
with the born as a way it was played
check i thought the worst is over but
it's still better from 44 black maybe I
shouldn't exchange Bishop so that's
possible that this was a mistake how did
you how did you ever check managed to
lose it at the end check this is quite
quite remarkable 5 around here the comps
assets equal at first check equal all
equal why this is why it's a sequel I
thought did you lose earn and some
temper this losers interesting oops
check this losses okay so you should
give the check and then go here I don't
understand this I'll go here ah so we
can you can give give checks from the
from the back check so this is this is a
draw I see a okay this is a draw can
always give those checks from from
the bank Wow okay well thanks for
watching